Well, of course GDP has been used for many years as a measure of quality of life, but
what we want, if we're measuring quality of
life, is we want to know how people are really
doing. And for several reasons, GDP really
doesn't get at that. First of all, it doesn't
take account of distribution. So it can give
very--it's an average--so it can give very
high marks to nations that have huge and alarming inequalities. Where the people at the top
may be doing very well so the average is high, but then a lot of people at the bottom are
living very miserable lives. Second, because it funnels all parts of human life together
in a single number, it doesn't really tell
you how people are doing in separate areas
of life that you really want to care about,
such as health, education, political liberty,
race relations. So they're so many things
that bear on the quality of a human life.
And you might argue that GDP is good proxy for all of them and that if you just simply
push for economic growth it'll trickle down
and improve these other things. But actually
that's not true. Empirical research by now
has show that health and education are not
very robustly correlated with increased GDP. In the different Indian states, health and
education are subjects that are left for the
states to manage, so you can use them as experimental
laboratories. And it's really quite interesting
to see that some that have shot for increased
GDP and have achieved that have very poor achievements in health and education, while
Kerala, which is a relatively poor state whose economy has not grown well actually has 99%
adolescent literacy in both males and females, and health achievements that are comparable
to inner city New York. Which is, I think,
shameful for New York but it's actually quite
fine for a poor Indian state. But then if
you think about political liberty, gender relations,
race relations, it's even more
obvious that that's not highly correlated
with GDP. I mean, everyone admires China for the stunning economic growth but we know very
well that there are lots of things that are
lacking there.
Well, the first time that the United Nations published a Human Development report using
this approach, the great Pakistani economist Mahbub ul Haq said
the real wealth of the nation is its people, and the purpose of development
is to create an enabling environment for people to live long, healthy, and creative lives.
So, that's the purpose of the approach, and so essentially it asks the very basic question:
what are people actually able to do and to
be, in a wide range of areas which are thought
to be of central importance for the quality
of a human life. Now, I've actually made a
list of ten because I'm interested in constitutional law and so I'm interested in the way that
you could actually write this down and put
it into constitutional documents.
But, other people don't make a list, but they pick out certain things to compare. And then you have
to figure out how to measure each of them.
So, what would be a good proxy for education?
And so, of course, data have to be reshaped to the new approach. And I think right now
the Human Development reports use mean years of schooling as a proxy for education, and
that's because they can get data on that.
It's much harder to get inside the school
and figure out exactly what people are able
to do. So I think we always need to be pushing
for better measures. It is, again, very hard
to know what you should be looking at when
you measure health. Health opportunities is what you really want to look at, not health
achievements, because we do think that people should have choices about how to live their
lives. And so what's important is that they
should have opportunities to have good health,
and then some may choose to live an unhealthy life. But there's a huge difference between
"fasting" and "starving," you know, and if
people are fasting for reasons of their own
choice, that's one thing. But if they're malnourished and they're starving, that's another. So it's
very hard to know how to measure that, and, of course, one of the things you just do is
look at the incidence of different kinds of
diseases, nutritional diseases. Then you
look at longevity, which, of course, is a
very good proxy for health opportunities.
Those books are about how political arrangements can address problems of human vulnerability,
and prior to that we have to ask "what forms of vulnerability should be addressed?"
Some forms of vulnerability, such as being open to love, or caring about your children,
we don't want to remove from human life. But we do want to support them and make them fruitful,
rather than sources of just constant, daily,
agonizing uncertainty. You know, so if you
think about my work on the emotions, it's
all really about love, and it's about
attachments that people have, and I'm certainly trying to send the mess  age that people should
not shrink from attachments. But then, you
know, it's just not the case that we want
people to be as vulnerable as possible when they have children and they love them.
No, you know, how would a decent society support that relationship of love and attachment and
make it not the case that you have to worry
from day to day, are my children going to
get their food or not? And so, yeah, thinking about how vulnerability plays out and how
good governments can leave room for the good kinds of vulnerability where you're open to
loving somebody, but get rid of the bad sorts where you're afraid that you're going to be
beaten up if you walk outside of your house, or you're afraid that your children might starve.
I guess the first thing to say is it's a persuasive document.
It's not meant to be imposed by force of arms or even by economic threats.
And actually I think those things are almost
never justified. I do think that when you're
thinking about what you want to fund, if you're a nation in the developed world, it might
make sense to give priority to things like
health and education. But most of the time,
I mean, I'm really a big supporter of national sovereignty, I think you should do it by giving
it to the nation and let them decide what
to do with it. So it's a template for nations
to consult when they think what they might
want to protect. And I have some arguments,
which I think are good arguments, that these are things that they should pay attention to,
so we hope that people will be persuaded. But it's certainly, I think it's not imperialism if
you try to persuade people of something. So that's the first thing to say.
Second thing is that it's, unless you defend certain things, you don't have meaningful pluralism.
For example, the freedom of speech, the freedom of association, the freedom of religion.
Unless you give those a very strong place in your nation, in your constitution, or whatever you have as your
founding document, then it's very hard for
meaningful pluralism to even exist.
So the relationship between universalism and pluralism is complicated, and you have to say "this,
we defend for everyone," if you're going to
have the difference and the plurality that
really I think we all want to see. Third thing
is that this is a list of capabilities and
it's not a list of functionings. It's not meant to dragoon people into pursuing one
of these. It's a set of opportunities. So,
you might hate religion and still think it's
a fine thing to protect the freedom of religion so that the people who do care about religion can use
it when they want to use it. Similarly, you
know, many of us love to work, we work a lot,
but we still think that there should be maximum hours protections and that people shouldn't
have to work all the time. They shouldn't,
lives should not be swallowed up by that,
so that if they want leisure time they should
be able to have it. You know, again, some
people may want to engage in fasting for religious reasons or personal reasons, but what's important
is they should have the opportunity to be
well-nourished. So I think that's a very permissive
approach, it's an approach that really is all
about opportunity and choice.
So, then the last thing I'll say is that because I'm thinking so much about constitutional law,
I think that what I put on my list is something extremely abstract and general, with the idea that each
nation will do it somewhat differently. And
that they'll take some abstract thing, like
"the freedom of speech," and then they'll
think what version of that they want to endorse.
As we know, different nations around the world have very different doctrines of free speech.
The doctrine of free speech in the U.S. is
extremely speech-protective, for example defending
anti-semitic protesting and marching in Skokie. Whereas in Germany, anti-semitic speech is illegal.
Well, I actually think both are right,
given their different histories and traditions.
So the whole point of the list is to say "well,
here's a kind of general idea, now you think
what you want to do with that in keeping with your history and traditions."